do you find any conspiracy theories
compelling
like have you pulled at the string of
the
of the rich complex world of conspiracy
theories that's out there
i think that uh i've heard a conspiracy
theory that conspiracy theories were
invented by the cia
in the 60s to discredit true things
yeah um so you know you can go to
ridiculous
conspiracy theories like flat earth and
pizzagate
and uh you know these things are almost
to hide like
conspiracy theories that like you know
remember when the chinese like locked up
the doctors who discovered coronavirus
like i tell people this and i'm like
no no that's not a conspiracy theory
that actually happened
do you remember the time that the money
used to be backed by gold and now it's
backed by nothing
this is not a conspiracy theory this
actually happened
well that's one of my worries today with
the idea of fake news
is that when nothing
is real then
like you dilute the possibility of
anything being true by
conjuring up all kinds of conspiracy
theories and then you don't know what to
believe and then
like the idea of truth of objectivity is
lost completely
everybody has their own truth so you
used to control information by censoring
it
then the internet happened and
governments are like oh [ __ ] we can't
censor things anymore
i know what we'll do you know it's the
old story of uh the story of like
tying a flag where the leprechaun tells
you the gold is buried and you tie one
flag and you make the leprechaun swear
to not remove the flag and you come back
to the field later with a shovel and
there's flags everywhere
that's one way to maintain privacy right
is like
in order to protect the contents of this
conversation for example we could just
generate like millions of deep fake
conversations where you and i
talk and say random things yeah so this
is just one of them and nobody knows
which one was the real one
this this could be fake right now
classic steganography technique
you